[Music]
welcome to hashtag news I'm Gabe ho
writer Game of Thrones has given us some
amazing battle scenes over the years
from Blackwater to Castle black - last
season showdown between Jon Snow and
some White Walkers this season will be
no different some major spoilers ahead
guys we're gonna tell you about a large
battle that will be fought right before
your very eyes this season get excited
okay according to a leaked set photo it
looks like this season will feature a
large battle to regain Winterfell and
rule the north check it out here looks
like we have some dire wolf sigils as
well as the Mormont Bear and possibly
the horn woods all sworn to the Starks
all right that's all very cool but the
question now is who's leading them well
some people have theories it could
somehow be the newly escapes Sansa or
the newly magical brand all sides
reporting to us somehow resurrected Jon
Snow this is leading some insiders to
call it the Battle of the bastards yes
love that word Jon Snow stark versus
Ramsay snow Bolton there will be
bastards
so this battle has been referred to as
the Battle of the six armies which also
sounds epic
I personally prefer battle the bastards
because I like alliteration on to the
burning questions let me know your
thoughts in the comments burning
question number one what is the status
of Jon Snow here does the name battle
the bastards mean we're pretty much
confirmed that Jon Snow is not only
resurrected but now he's leader of the
Starks and if so does that mean that
he's Jon Stark now or maybe he'd prefer
the title new king of the north yeah
zero to hero baby pretty question number
two yeah just just the one - who will
win
I know Bolton's army is nothing to laugh
at here seeing as how Stannis and his
men were no match but that was also a
purchased army he'll probably be
different when the Starks are in the
fight and I actually care what they're
fighting for burning question number 3
good flames those are flames we usually
only get one huge battle per season in
Game of Thrones but with the white
Walker so close now is it the biggest
battle of the season or can we expect
more with this obviously being a huge
moment for the Starks you have to wonder
if some of the other family members are
gonna play a role I actually think they
will I have a video where I talk all
about that right there subscribe for
more game of Thrones coverage you guys
if we were you guys we probably
subscribe i'm gabe hill writer and
winter can't get here soon enough it's
really hot in this room is what i mean
can we can we get the air on
we get the air off sure thanks